Hauptstadt Berlin Wasserwege durch 10
Millionen Metropole die Spree sehen
Kanäle hier tobt das Leben aber wer App
war beim Landwehrkanal zwischen Neukölln
und Kreuzberg genau hinschaut sieht
hinter den Massen der Flaneure und
feiern dann immer mehr Zelte in den
Büschen hier leben die flussmenschen von
Berlin
wir haben mit vier Wohnungslosen
gesprochen die einen Einblick in ihr
Leben gewähren
hier von der Brücke bist du der Brücke
denke ich mal sind 13 Leute und das ist
nicht wenig auf dem kleinen Stück ich
bin nicht alleine
140 Euro pro Tag das ist das andere
[Musik]
meine Familie
auf der Welt und sein Leben zu leben und
ich weiß nicht einmal
dabei ist der Kontrast hart die
Einkaufen in Luxusläden Edelmarken und
genießen die Sonne
die anderen können bei den extrem
gestiegenen Mietpreisen nicht mehr
mithalten sie liegen ein paar Meter
weiter unter elendsten Bedingungen
zwischen den Büschen am Ufer hier haben
sie ein wenig Ruhe und Wasser
wie sie ist einer der Obdachlosen die
ihr Hausen er erzählt seine Geschichte
ja also das ist ja nicht so dass man
irgendwie sich irgendwie jetzt eine
Matratze im Schlafsack jetzt irgendwo
hinlegen kann und schlafen kann sondern
auch abends geht dann erstmal hier der
Tanz los ne also hier sind so viele
Ratten so viel Ungeziefer Ameisen also
das ist keine gefährlichen jetzt
Insekten aber die Ratten
wenn du irgendwo ein kleines Stückchen
Essen drin hast die fressen sich durch
jede Tüte und holen sich das Essen da
raus also das ist wirklich krass also
abends hast du auch diese diese diese
Geräusche was da wo du genau weißt ein
Meter neben dir ist eine Ratte aber weil
es dunkel ist siehst du die nicht aber
du hörst die und das macht einen so so
verrückt ne dass das so weiße irgendwo
sind hier die Ratten und warten nur bis
du einschließt ne das ist nicht beklauen
können
aber es ist es ist wirklich krass ey
also Kanal und Kanalratten das hat schon
eine Bedeutung
ja klar also wie gesagt also hier ist
mein mein Rucksack mit dem bin ich immer
unterwegs da oben verstecke ich meine
Sachen und legt legt meine meine
Isomatte liege ich da drüber damit das
so ein bisschen versteckt ist
und das nehme ich als Sichtschutz wenn
ich schlafe wegen den Leuten hier habe
ich meine Kerze abends wenn mache ich
die manchmal an
ja gestern habe ich hier so ein
gefunden
vom Flohmarkt da die Schere die kann ich
gut gebrauchen ne Fingernägel schneiden
und so aber das sind so alte Sachen wie
gesagt aber die helfen mir ne dann habe
ich gestern meinen Teil zusammengesucht
mein Kupfergeld ja und ich versuche das
hier auch sauber zu halten das ist mir
wichtig
weil wie sie seinen Ausweis verlor
bekommt er kein Geld vom Staat wenn er
mit dem Fahrrad unterwegs ist kann er am
Tag Pfandflaschen im Wert von 20 Euro
sammeln das reicht für etwas zu essen
und eine Kugel Heroin
man in der lernzigarettenschachtel habe
ich meine Röhrchen
so und dann bin ich wenn ich jetzt
eine Alufolie habe dann mache ich meinen
Heroin drauf
rauche ich rauche ich das indem ich das
von unten erhitze und durch das Röhrchen
zieht dann den Pfeil ein und dann
das ist Iren das ist macht ein macht
eine sehr
sehr benebelt
man gewöhnt sich schnell dran das ist
das Schlimme du brauchst es später dann
einfach nur das ist dir gesund eh das
ist dir körperlich gut geht weil dieser
Entzug ist körperlich und das ist das
Schlimme ein heroine am Anfang ist klar
wie sie sagt es werden mehr und mehr
Wohnungslose
hier von der Brücke bis zu der Brücke
denke ich mal sind 13 Leute und das ist
nicht wenig auf dem kleinen Stück hier
in Berlin hast du überhaupt keine Chance
irgendwie privat eine Wohnung zu finden
ich kenne jemand der sucht eine Wohnung
schon seit vier Jahren
es gibt natürlich irgendwie
so kurz kurzfristige Sachen gesehen dass
dass du irgendwie für ein paar Monate im
Zimmer mieten kannst aber dann musst du
da auch raus z.B und Geld vom Staat bist
oder nicht
wegen meinem Ausweis habe ich das
Problem dass ich jetzt im Moment nichts
machen kann
ich muss gucken dass ich beim
bei der melde mich mich da irgendwie
mitnehmen mit einem Passbild dann
irgendwie einen Termin hole und mir dann
aus und beantrage es eigentlich nicht
schwer
aber wie gesagt er ist das Geld
zurücklegen ist schwierig ne weil du
hast Drogen im Kopf was andere Sachen im
Kopf was essen im Kopf du hast Trinken
im Kopf da wo du das Geld
sicher haben muss obwohl du weißt
auf längere Zeit hinaus ist der Ausweis
wichtiger weil dann kriegst du auf
wenigstens wieder dieses Bürgergeld
[Musik]
ein wenig weiter stehen im Gebüsch noch
mehr Zelte die ab und zu Besuch von
einer Katze bekommen hier lebt auch der
Pole Rafael mir schlecht als recht
du wohnst auch in so einem Zelt
ich habe keine Zeit für Arbeit
[Musik]
vielleicht
ich habe viel Freunde das nicht ich bin
nicht alleine
140 Euro pro Tag das ist das andere
weißt du was
ich kommen
so viele Leute so viel Leute und habe
Angst
aber Junkie von diese Worte ist
Mensch nicht
ich bin ein Mensch
vielleicht morgen ich krank deine
Caravan ist nicht weiß
aber das ist egal
denkst du eine
nach paar Tagen
bulgarischer
deutsche Leute was lieber hier und ich
weiß von weißt du wie viel ich habe pro
Tag eine
Villa
30.000 Euro pro Tag und 30 000
ich weiß dass du trotzdem 30 000 €
was hat Minimum 55
es ist ein trauriges Leben wenn Rafal
zwei Flaschen Whisky im Wert von 40 Euro
klaut bekommt er durch den Verkauf der
Hehlerware gerade mal 10 Euro genug für
eine Kugel Heroin von denen braucht der
4 bis 5 am Tag
manche Wohnungslose sind erfinderisch
hier hat einer ein kleines Zimmer in
einen Kasten eines Rohres gebaut das
über den Kanal führt
[Musik]
Reza hat es nur zu einem Zelt gebracht
er stammt aus dem Iran und ist durch
seine Drogensucht auf der Straße
gelandet
[Musik]
in for use der
wird nach oben
ist meine meine Decke meine Matratze
genau
mit meiner Freundin
Mutter und das vorassungslicht ist Lampe
auf voll Ass und Nazi weiter ist das wie
ist morgen
es ist live is not gut really
durch die Sucht verlor er seine Frau und
den Kontakt zu seinen beiden kleinen
Söhnen
Baby eleven years hier just I have
normal Ausweis hast
sehr gut er kann die Mose
much
elevenirsadmaykante ein mit kickboxing
du bist die kickboxx und da kam mir in
Deutschland
in Deutschland
erzählt wie er täglich sucht und
hamstert und sein Überleben und seine
Sucht zu finanzieren
und am Tag zum Edeka oder hier ist fort
Polizei
[Musik]
Problem
Mutter
hier in Deutsch Mutter
es ist ein hartes Leben am Kanal in dem
er sich wenigstens ab und zu mal die
Hände waschen kann
what you dream you
gesetzt
meine Familie
ja das ist die Tasche meine Kühlschrank
oder also
meine Kühlschrank
auf das Essen in meiner Brot oder meine
Sachen ja wir mussten aber Tiere kein
Problem kein Geheimnis
so leben die Wohnungslosen in den
Büschen am Kanal nur ein Sound brennt
vom Gehweg
[Musik]
ein paar Kilometer weiter den
Landwehrkanal hinunter treffen wir ein
Streuner in ein Park der genauso sein
will in Freiheit unter freiem Himmel
reif ist schon sehr lange auf Triebe und
will nicht mehr in vier Wänden leben
also wie lange bist du denn schon auf
der Straße 12 Jahre
seitdem ich 28 seitdem ich 16
das ist wirklich seitdem so aggressiv
geworden ist seitdem alle hier
reingelassen worden sind und das ist
doch wirklich so also nicht nur aus
Drittstaaten sondern auch aus Polen die
ganzen nicht alle also es ist aber sehr
viele gewesen die uns hier alles viel
kaputt gemacht haben von schnorrendes
keine Ahnung was so also davon hatte ich
früher mal mehr gehabt und mittlerweile
kannst du auch kaum noch leisten
also du meinst durch die den Zuzug von
vielen vielen Flüchtlingen Migranten ist
die Straße ist die Situation auf der
Straße härter geworden das ist auch
wirklich die Wahrheit also das ist das
ist also das beobachte ich jedes Mal und
das kann ich auch so bestätigen jedes
Mal wenn ich am Zelten bin oder so kommt
immer irgendein Rumänien und versuche
meine Pfandflaschen zu glauben
mittlerweile lassen die mich in Ruhe so
weiß gar nicht warum ich meine Arche
Berlin
sehr schwer geworden man hat auch nicht
mehr viele im Leben so das ist
man weiß gar nicht mehr was jetzt die
nächsten Jahre kommt noch der Krieg
kommt oder sonstiges oder so ich bin mir
schon sicher dass wir kriegen ja
ausbrechen wird
irgendwie Hilfe vom Staaten bisschen
Geld nee das ist äh das macht richtig
krank das ist immer nur mit Forderungen
gewertet und da ist ja irgendwie nicht
chillen so eigentlich ist da der Mensch
dafür da auf der Welt und sein Leben zu
leben und äh ich weiß nicht einmal jedes
Mal wird mir gesagt ich soll was für die
Wirtschaft arbeiten also bitte so soll
ich mich für die Wirtschaft kaputt
machen und erleben dafür wegwerfen und
deshalb froh dass ich meine Jugend
ausgelegt ne habe und was drin ist
[Musik]
zu Entspannung braucht gerne Marihuana
so kann er den harten Alltag ein
bisschen vergessen
er denkt dann über vieles nach
so
was soll ich mit einer Wohnung da
drinnen psychisch kaputt und wissen nur
dick und das ist ich habe gestern schon
in den Nachrichten gehört im Radio und
dass das irgendwie auch ungesund ist
ständig in der Wohnung zu sitzen und zu
essen so ich bin ständig im Training ich
habe Muskulatur auch wenn ich dick bin
und Bauch habe noch und
vielleicht noch leichten aber das ist
mir völlig egal so
da quasi gezwungen sich anzumelden und
dann mache ich einfach nicht also ich
lasse mir sowieso nichts vorschreiben
ich komme aus dem Ruhrpott mein Opa hat
reichere berschmann und ich wollte auch
mal die Zeche und das hat man heute
leider uns irgendwie verderbärabzeichen
mal durch die scheiß Politik und ja das
ist
sehr deprimierend sowas ist
einfach Kultur im Europa hat irgendwie
tot machen mit irgendwelche klimascheiße
dann sollte man einfach nur die
Flugzeuge lassen
[Musik]
ich bin halt echt voll der Erfolg
gefahren und mag eigentlich keine
Kameras oder das ist halt echt eine
Ausnahme eigentlich Journalisten aber
das ist auch noch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
seinem Kastenwagen weiter durch die
Städte ziehen
[Musik]
anders als diese Polen und Bulgaren
unter einer Spreebrücke ist er ein
Einzelgänger
[Musik]
Neukölln sozialstadtrat Hannes Rehfeld
von der CDU ist für das Thema Obdachlose
in seinem Bezirk verantwortlich er sagt
ein großes Problem sei der schleppende
Wohnungsbau das ist Berlin weit so dass
wir schlicht nicht wissen wie viele
Obdachlose wir haben was wir wissen ist
dass es einfach sichtbarer wird das hat
verschiedene Gründe unter anderem das
ehemalige brachen immer mehr wegfallen
das Rückzugsräume wegfallen und dadurch
wird die Obdachlosigkeit im öffentlichen
Raum jedenfalls sichtbarer man könnte
zum Beispiel damit die schwächsten der
schwachen auch eine Chance haben eine
Wohnung zu bekommen neue Wohnung bauen
und das hat Berlin jahrelang nicht oder
jedenfalls nicht ausreichend getan
jedenfalls Fantasien wie Enteignung oder
ähnliches kann dieses Problem nicht
lösen denn jeder enteignete oder
vergesellschaftete Wohnung ist im
Zweifel belegt
die gerade bekannt wurde müssen viele
Bezirke wegen Löchern im Haushalt extrem
sparen in Neukölln sind es für die Jahre
2024 25 und 23 Millionen Euro weniger
davon wird auch die Obdachlosenhilfe
betroffen sein
es wurden einfach in den vergangenen
Jahren von der Vorgängerregierung so
viele Ausgaben getätigt so viele
Versprechungen gemacht
so viele politische wunschprojekte das
jetzt einfach kein Geld mehr da ist und
das fällt uns jetzt auf die Füße und
damit müssen wir Bezirke muss aber auch
das ganze Land und der neue Senat
irgendwie umgehen wir haben den
Wohnungsbau zu beschleunigen und dann
eben auch für soziale Zwecke mehr
Wohnung zur Verfügung stellen zu können
es ist natürlich wichtig dass die
bauvorbereitenden Maßnahmen schneller
werden dass
Regeln verringert werden dass es
einfacher wird überhaupt eine
Baugenehmigung zu kommen und das eben
dann diese das was gebaut wird auch zu
vernünftigen Preisen angeboten werden
kann und das ist richtig dass der Senat
vor hat da auch Regelungen und Vorgaben
soweit es in Landes Zuständigkeit liegt
auch zu entschlacken
ob diese Leute die im Elend am Wasser
leben von irgendwelchen politischen
Änderungen profitieren werden ist
zweifelhaft sie haben sich gewöhnt an
das raue Leben im Freien die
flussmenschen von Berlin
[Musik]